Hey everyone, we are now in the second video of this indirect price discrimination look.
And here we're going to be looking at how pricing menus can be used to reveal customers willingness to pay.
As opposed to looking at offering different versions of a product or different products, we're going to be looking at how the consumer through pricing can allow us to indirectly price discriminate.
So here we're going to let the consumer choose.
But what happens when the product remains the same?
In this case, what we want to do is look at the different pricing structures or create what we call a pricing menu.
So the same product is there.
But now we offer a pricing menu to these consumers and allow them to choose what they want to consume based off that pricing menu.
So here we'll be looking at things like volume discounts, bundling and usage fees to help us indirectly price discriminate into these markets.
So let's go ahead and jump into our first one which was volume discounts.
Now this one occurs whenever we have a lower unit price for buying more.
So here, customers who buy more paid less per unit, but they still pay more in total.
So our high value, high volume buyers, they're going to pay a lot more for what they have, but they paid less per unit.
So again, if you think about paper towels as a particular example, as you purchase more and more paper towels, you will notice that the per unit paper towel roll price is actually lower than if you just bought two rolls of paper towels.
If you compare buying 24 versus 2, the per unit cost there is a lot less than it is for just the two, but you overall pay more for it.
So that again allows the firm to extract more of that consumer surplus from from those types of consumers.
Now a second way that companies can offer the same product and do it at different effective prices is by using what we call two part tariffs.
Here you charge an entry fee or an access fee, and then you charge a per unit fee for something else that's included inside of that particular product.
So here we're going to see the low and high value users both get access to the product that you're offering.
But then you find that the high value users end up paying more for any additional add ons that go along with the particular product that you're offering.
So if you're the classic example of gym membership, where you pay $50 per month to get access to the gym and all the equipment, all that good stuff, but then there might be a variable cost that's imposed upon the person, the high value consumer, who wants to go to the Pilates classes, the yoga classes or whatever it is that goes along that's extra inside of that gym membership.
So that is a way to look at a two part tariff.
You could also do the same thing for sports tickets where you charge a consumer a, an access fee to have an access to the seat for the, for the season.
And then you charge them the individual game prices or ticket prices for those individual games as the season goes on.
So that's a way to capture more of that surplus from those consumers and through the two part tariff.
Now bundling is another way to look at our how to extract more consumer surplus out of the market when we do not know how our consumers are segmented.
Now, bundling occurs whenever a firm is selling two or more products together.
As a patent, we also call this a package tie in sale.
And another important thing about bundling here is that firms are going to be using it whenever consumers value goods differently.
That is, you have two consumers looking at two at a good, but one consumer values it highly, one values it lowly.
The valuations are uncorrelated or negatively correlated.
And that simply means that you have two people who look at the same good, or excuse me, they look at two different goods that are going to be bundled together.
One consumer values one good and has no value whatsoever in the other good.
But the other consumer values the good that the prior consumer had no value on.
But then they value, they don't value the other good that the prior consumer had anything on.
I'm going to make that a little bit more explicit here as we move on.
Now there are two types of bundling that we deal with.
The first is pure bundling here.
The only way to purchase the items is through the bundle.
So you cannot purchase these items separately.
They have to come together in a bundle.
A classic way to look at this is through the classic or traditional cable TV package where you buy a bunch of channels for one price.
Now there's also some versioning that goes on.
You can buy tiered subscriptions or tier packages, but you can't buy those channels separately.
So I might want hbo, but I might not want espn, or I might want espn, but I might not want Discovery.  Well, guess what?
I have to get them all together inside of that same package.
Now this works best whenever the standalone value is unclear.
And what we mean by that is that consumers aren't really sure how much it's worth to them on its own, that is how much each product is worth them on its own.
So in this case it's actually really good for the company to pull them all together and then sell them as a bundle.
Now our next type of bundling is mixed bundling.
Here consumers can buy those items together or they can buy them separately.
But we will find that consumers get a discount from purchasing them together.
Classic example is fast food.
You can purchase the burger, fries and soda or all separately.
Or you could buy the combo which is going to give you a discount compared to if you bought all those items separately.  Here.
This is going to encourage those high value users to actually go out and get the bundle as opposed to getting them separately.
Whereas the low value users, they might just buy one of the items separately and then they'll care for the rest of the items.
Now why bundling works because it captures more consumer surplus.
Before you might have a, if you had one price for a good and it was priced too high, you would lose a consumer inside of that market.
So you lose that consumer surplus.
But by combining items together and selling them for a lower price than what you otherwise would, you can attract more low value users into the purchase of that product, which leads into smoothing out those value gap.
And then here all that simply means is that when you bring customers several items together inside of a bundle, you're going to get a consumer who might value one item in that bundle, but doesn't really care for other items inside that bundle, but because it comes at a price that is comfortable for them, they're gonna be wanting, they'll be willing to buy that particular item.
So for example, let's say that you're buying Microsoft Office.
You really don't care about PowerPoint, but maybe you really do like using Excel.
So if it comes together as a bundle at a price that's agreeable to you, you're more willing to purchase that bundle than might add a standalone value with just Excel.
And you definitely don't want PowerPoint.
Another example here is think about Spotify and their audio books there.
So here, why would you pay $12 just for one of those audiobooks?
But when you bring it together inside of a bundle now it becomes an add on inside of that premium and it looks much more enticing to you.
And then finally consumers again are allowed to self select into the, the, the, the high value, low value that we want them to because we cannot segment the market because it's just too difficult for us.
So now let's take a look at an example here.
And let's look at this table.
We have good one and good two.
We have a low value consumer and a high value consumer.
For good one, the low value consumer only wants or values that at $100.
The high value consumer values it at $150 for good two, the low value consumer values at $50 and the high value consumer values it at $75.
So our first question, what to price good one to maximize revenue?
So if I price good one at $150, what we'll notice is I only get the high valued user.
If I price it at $100, I get the low and high valued user.
So if I do that, I get $200 total from selling good one to the low value and high value users.
So that's a $50 gain over just selling it for $150 to the high value user, what to price good to to maximize revenue.
So in this case, let's look at the low value and high value again.
So $50 for the low value user, $75 for the high value user.
And if I price it at $75, I lose the low value user.
But if I price it at 50, I gain both the low value and high value user and I get a total of $100 in revenue, which would be $25 greater than the $75 that I would just generate from the high value user.
So here price it at $50.
And then our last question, how can the firm maximize revenue?
Well, we already know that to get both of these consumers in the market, we're going to price at the low value users valuation.
So if I bundle these two goods together for $150, I can sell both of them together for $150 each to the low value and high value users.
So this then gives me $300 total in revenue versus the 225 if I bundled it at $225 just for the high value user.
So bundle those goods for $150, you make a total of $300 and you come out better.
Let's move on to our next example here, our next topic, and that's going to be tie in sales.
And this occurs when a firm requires a customer to purchase a complimentary good repeatedly.
Now, this is more specifically called a requirement tie in sale.
We previously saw the package tie in sale which dealt with bundling.
But now we're looking at these requirement tie ins.
Now, with these types of sales, typically what we're going to be seeing is that the base product here is going to act more like fee to get to the second product that is this, this first product might be sold at cost or at near cost in order to get the second product, which is going to be the higher margin product to be bought repeatedly by the consumer.
So this is going to allow the firm to price discriminate based on usage.
So heavy users are going to be consuming more, they're going to have a higher willingness to pay for it and that therefore it's going to reveal a higher margin for that firm.
Whereas the light users, they aren't going to buy as much of the product, but they, and they're gonna pay less overall, but they still are buying both of the products together.
And again, this is another classic example of not having to have different versions of your product, but just having a different price menu here because you don't need to figure out what the customer type is.
You just give them a price menu and then allow them to determine how much they're going to purchase based off of their willingness to pay and how much value they get from that particular product.
So here are some examples of tie in sales.
We have base products that tied good in the explanation as to why these two things work.
The inkjet printer ink cartridges are the classic example.
When you look at office offices, you have companies that come in, they'll sell the inkjet printer, but then they have to tie in the ink cartridges to go with it.
And a lot of times the maintenance as well has to be tied into the purchase of that inkjet printer.
And here what we end up seeing is that the printer is actually pretty cheap.
Their technology and the expense goes into the ink.
All right, let's look at another one, the soda fountain machine.
The syrup concentrate is the tide in good.
So if you ever go to a soda fountain machine and you go to your Coke or your Pepsi or whatever happens to be, you'll notice that there are two distinct looking liquids that are coming out.
One is the carbonated soda or water, and the other is the actual syrup concentrate that mixes in with the carbonated water.
And in this case, what we're seeing here is that combines to make your drink.
But the profits here are actually coming from those ongoing syrup purchases because they're a little bit more expensive, they have a higher margin locked into them.
So let's, so let's finish this up by looking at why these strategies work.
And quite simply, we have these as why they work here.
Customers do reveal their value through their choice and usage.
So their own willingness to pay is going to help us understand how much the consumer actually wants to consume for us.
Pricing strategies help firms segment invisibly Again, indirect price discrimination.
We don't know what kind of consumers we have.
And so through these particular strategies, we don't have to worry about that.
We just set up the pricing menu and then allow those consumers to sort into the amount that they want.
These tools work best when product costs are constant and usage varies.
So here we don't have to worry about charging everyone the same amount.
And then lastly, they're more flexible, inclusive and profitable than one size fits all pricing.
So we, we can allow those firms to capture more value across all the consumer segments simply by pricing differently in this market.  And that is it.
I hope you've enjoyed it.